Definitely a lot of Americans can't tell the difference between a lot of British
accents. Well, I can get that. Yeah.
American folks, like where are you from in Australia? I'm like, uh, I'm not,
I don't know why British Australia seems to care.
Do you get mixed up quite well? Even though I think to us, it's like,
it's complete opposite. Yeah.
But I think to me, Australia acts is a really different.
He doesn't sound bad Australian. I don't sound as no,
no, he doesn't sound, I don't sound as Australian as I used to
dust that to a man. If you go back,
if you go back like the early in my channel, I sound Australian as YouTube.
Very Northern. Yeah. I mean,
do you not sound less British as you've gone.
In Japan? Week one,
I landed in Yamagata and my three teachers who I was going to work with and meet
me at the airport. And I was like, it.
It's such a long flight raves hide in the closet. And they're like, I,
for one hour we ate like a dentist and they just kept talking and talking.
They kept going after this. They were like, we don't,
we didn't know what you were saying.
I never do the Japanese. Hello.
They're like, we don't know what you were saying. Oh yeah. And from then on,
I was like, hello, my name is Chris. I'm from London.
They're reign the UK. You know,
I might have to change my voice really like Royal pronunciation. Oh eight.
Then it'd be a little tight. Can I used to say.
Do you find sometimes that you speak almost like broken English sometimes to.
I've tried to stop doing that.
A lot of English teachers in Japan do the stupid voice.
Like I went shopping with my friends yesterday and they're like, do like really?
I don't see it. Right. Yeah. You got it.
I'll talk to people and I'll just deconstruct my English live just because I'm
like, I think they'll understand if I say it this way, but then,
but then I'll go on to speak to God and I'll be like, hi, gaunt.
How are you today? You know.
Environment where for weeks at a time,
I was the only foreigner around speaking English.
My English level actually went down,
not being able to speak English for like a month. It's really weird.
I've had issues as a result, but like, yeah, my vocabulary level went down.
I couldn't say words like in consequential or that wouldn't come up.
[Inaudible] that just came to your mind. I was like, what,
what is going to be a word.
To get it? I'll be like, Oh, it's like, just wouldn't come out. I had that too.
That like, when I first worked in a Japanese here, I worked in Niseko.
It's like a big ski resort in Hokkaido. Yes.
And I worked there for a month and it was like a kind of show, snow shovel,
general stuff around the lobbies and stuff.
But all of the people who I worked with were just hundred percent from Hokkaido,
like old Japanese people.
So I was forced to basically speak Japanese for a month straight.
And I remember I came back to Australia and I was like, Oh,
it's only been a month. Right. I'm like, of course this English,
my first language, of course, I'm not going to forget it.
But then I Australia was like, what was that word again?
I would actually forget. So consequential concert something or all a.
I don't, I don't know how to say it hard. You know,
it was just really difficult.
In, in terms of like dumbing down your language. When speaking to like,
you know, Japanese speakers,
I feel like anyone who has come from like a bilingual parents or like is
bilingual and has had like Asian or parents who don't speak your native language
as well. It's something I've just grown up with. Cause whenever I,
whenever I speak to my parents, like mostly like for example,
when I speak to my mom, I'm mostly speaking Thai,
but when I have to express something in English,
I like very much have to dumb down my language.
Very careful about how I word things.
Because especially like learning a language, you know,
how their grammar structure is. So, you know,
like sometimes you hear a Japanese people, like Japanese person speak,
try to speak English. And he's like,
you understand what their like mentality is or what their like train of thought
is when I try and just like construct a sentence, kind of like, well,
you kind of learned to do is kind of mirror the way that they would construct a
sentence so that they would eat more easily on the understand. Yeah.
Especially what I find myself doing. Yeah. But also I forget like, um,
so I'll think of the word in Welsh. I'll be,
and I'll remember the Japanese word for it. And I'm like, what the is it?
Which one is it? And then vice versa, I'll be speaking Japanese.
And I'll be like, Oh, why is the Welsh word? Keep popping up in my head?
And I'm trying to think of the right word. It's a mess.
Cause I obviously don't use those languages as much as I use English.
So my head they're slowly like amalgamating together. And it's, it's awful.
I guess you're kind of getting to the point and, and you as all gone,
you kind of,
you guys can until the point where you'll learning a third language. Right?
I mean, yeah. I mean, I, I tried to image this for you as a,
technically like a third language you're trying to learn or I trying to get.
I try and use it as much as possible. I mean, I'm, I'm doing like, uh, on the,
my new second channel.
Whoa, wow.
Uh, doing a series where, um, uh,
I guess playing games with Japanese people and using what broken Japanese I
have. And sometimes I'm like about to say a word I'm like, Nope, that's,
that's the Welsh word. But if you haven't watched that, who's going to watch it.
If you want to see my terrible, my terrible Japanese and action.
But I do find that that has been the best practice I've had,
which is just talking because yeah,
unfortunately I'm at a very privileged situation where I don't need to talk to
Japanese people, which are, you know.
If you could get a Japanese girlfriend every day is a language lesson.
What if they speak fluent English? Well, I screen.
He's just going to be speaking English. Right?
Would you not find the communication would be an issue if you could?
Well, I dated the Japanese go East of arguments. I just didn't know what were,
what was going on English angry. She didn't speak English very well.
I didn't speak Japanese very well at the time.
Didn't know what we were arguing about because we just had your phones out with
Google translate. Yeah.
Cause when you, when you think about it, when you think about it English,
we have so many ways to convey levels of upset that are so precise.
I feel that it's almost like impossible to translate that to a non native
speaker.
I mean, it's, you know, it's the whole idea of like the word, right?
Like that can be used in literally any emotion, but trying to, I had to,
I had to explain that to one of my Japanese friends,
because he had heard of that word before, but he was like,
what does that actually mean?
Well, it's kind of use your imagination.
I said it, it can mean anything. He was like, what, what does that mean?
My experience teaching my Japanese friends word. It's dangerous.
Cause they'll just use it.
Yeah. [inaudible]
Amanda Love hotel when he referred to it as a scary point. Um,
but the thing is he would be completely corrected.
He was trying to say was, this is a scary place. Scary, scary.
There's some reason why I've been meeting Japanese people online or video games.
They seem to only know the worst words. Like for one,
this one guy kept telling me he had a Magnum chin, chin.
And I was like, how do you know what the word Magnum?
How would you know who taught you this? Ooh, how do you find this out?
I love how he knows the one Magnum.
It was just the, yeah. The daikon Magnum chin chin. It was so strange.
It sounds like a rockstar
rock Magnum mochi, Jim. It was great.
It asks me about my Dick size live on stream and I'm like,
are you sure you want to? Okay.
Because sports good sports. It's so good. I learned that there's also, uh,
they have, uh, a term and gaming in Japan where they have real tamale.
Yeah. So when you, when you game online with people,
they're not the real friends. Right? When sometimes if you're busy, you're like,
Oh, I'm playing with real tamale.
[inaudible] is like the equivalent of like IRR. Yeah. Which is like funny.
Cause it's like, you're not real, real interesting. My gaming friends.
I've I've I've been learning a lot. Yeah.
During that. Yeah. There's a, there's a lot of like Japanese,
I guess like internet slang. You'll learn from playing with.
Japanese. Yeah. Luckily I've been playing with one guy and he's been,
he's been figuring out how to like dumb things down for me,
which is good because sometimes he talks too fast.
Like throwing out like two channel lingo. They never use like, like any, uh,
they always use like plain form and stuff like that.
And for a lot me to like this isn't all of my classes. What's all this nonsense.
Where is the [inaudible] what's up?
What's going on here?
I feel like what Tashi? Why's the biggest lie you learn once you Illingworth.
Nobody says that. Um, Duolingo, it,
it constantly throws what Tashi nonstop at you.
And then the first thing you learn, right?
Every Japanese textbook in every classroom.
And then you talk to them and you're like, so that was a lie.
And he messaged me every everyday saying they've learned Japanese from Duolingo.
It doesn't prepare you for Japanese. Do you really know?
It's quite fun. But like, it way prepare you on the mini game. It is,
it helps with vocab, but that's also as far as it goes.
But even then I cause sometimes Duolingo will try and teach you Kanji before
it's even taught you all the Huracan and Casco, which blows my mind.
Same did do that.
I think we've talked about like teaching you like algebra before you've learned
multiplication, right? It's like why?
Yeah. Julie goes, all right, but like human, Japanese really good app.
I recommend it is paid for,
but it's like a free light version paying for an app. If it actually is good.
It is really, I used it that first year, human, Japanese, human, Japanese,
intermediate, everyone I've recommended to loves it.
So if you're learning Japanese, you're like really starting tomorrow afternoon,
human Japanese,
amazing to recommend the Yankee textbooks they get after like you've done
Japanese studying for like six Japanese. You've started studying tomorrow.
You're coming to Japan.
That is the app you get kind of really helped me in my first year,
coming here as a teacher, I recommend it. Not sponsored, not sponsored.